in other videos we have already talked
about the idea of gdp in some depth
gross domestic product a measure of the
aggregate goods and services produced in
a country in a year but what we're going
to discuss in this video is how good a
measure gdp is and in particular some of
the things that gdp does not measure
so in general what's the motivation for
wanting to know the aggregate goods and
services produced by a country
well you could view it as a sign of
economic activity so it's economic
economic activity
you could view it as the size or
influence of an economy
size
influence
of economy
and then if you take gdp and you divide
by the number of people in a country you
get things like gdp per capita
gdp per
capita we could view really as gdp per
head and this you could view as well
that's an indicator of well-being
with the idea that well if there's just
more goods and services produced per
person then maybe people in that country
are going to be better off but as we
already touched on what is it not
measuring
well one thing that gdp does not measure
is
non-marketed goods what do i mean by
non-marketed goods
so let's say that i have to go to the
airport so this is the airport here my
best drawing it's a terminal there's a
plane
that's the point of this isn't to draw
an airport but you get the idea that's
an airport and i need to go from my
house to the airport if i call up a taxi
or an uber or lyft or something like
that and i take it to
the airport so they drive me to that
airport
that fare that they charge me that will
be included in gdp
on the other hand if i were to get my
wife to drive me to the airport all of a
sudden that would not be counted in gdp
even though the exact same service has
been performed someone took me in their
car from my house to the airport and
that's because my wife or your roommate
or your best friend giving you a ride is
a non-marketed service they're not
trying to sell that service they're just
doing that to you as a favor but it was
a service provided to you but it would
not be captured in gdp
one that is often talked about is
child care
if that's my best drawing of a child
really fast
if you hire a babysitter or if you hire
a nanny to take care of your child that
should be included in gdp although if
you yourself take care of your child
that will not be included in gdp because
once again you taking care of your child
would be a non-marketed service
now the other thing that gdp does not
include are illegal activity or you
could even say under the table activity
some of which is not illegal for example
if someone were to pay their babysitter
and if it doesn't get registered in
taxes someplace well even that will not
be reflected in the gdp number it's not
an illegal activity but it should have
officially been registered with the irs
and then it would have been counted as
gdp but in this case it wouldn't have
and also of course you have black
markets illegal activity that for sure
would not be included in gdp
if someone were to illegally sell you
fireworks let's say they're banned in
your state and of course they're not
going to report it to the government
well of course that good and or service
is not going to be reflected in gdp
but you might say okay that's all right
you're going to miss some things but
directionally if gdp is growing
especially if gdp per capita is growing
surely that is a good thing and in
general you're probably right it
probably is a good thing but there's
also things that gdp is not capturing it
is not capturing even if you were able
to measure non-marketed goods and
services or under the table or illegal
activity it doesn't capture things like
let's say pollution
you could have a country whose gdp is
growing very very fast but in the
process the country gets very very
polluted maybe that makes the quality of
life go down in certain areas
health is another issue in general
countries with a high gdp per capita
usually do have good health care mainly
because of their they have more
resources for health care but you want
to look at that how how is the health
trending in a country and then you could
even think about stuff like stress or a
feeling of community or support these
are all things that would affect any
human being's well-being but they are
not of course captured in gdp
now to appreciate the different ways of
ranking countries in an attempt to get
at well-being you could first of all
look at gdp rankings
so here are rankings by the world bank
for
2016. you see the united states is on
top with
18.6 almost trillion dollars of gdp as
measured by the world bank and you see
the ranking
now if you wanted to go by per capita
because you say hey this is this is this
doesn't tell you how many people are
there what matters is how much good how
much productivity divided by the number
of people if you want to really measure
per person well-being well then you
might look at something like this gdp
per capita and notice here the united
states is still quite high but it's
nowhere near as high as luxembourg the
reason why luxembourg didn't show up on
the other list is it is a very very
small country its population is very
small compared to the united states same
thing for switzerland or for macau now
another thing to appreciate is this gdp
per capita just takes the nominal gdp
and divides it by the number of people
there are in a country but it does not
measure or indicate things like wealth
inequality it's not that every person in
luxembourg gets exactly a hundred and
three thousand dollars worth of goods
and services depending on the country
there might be more of a middle class or
less of a middle class there might be
more wealth inequality or less wealth
inequality and once again that is not
captured by gdp
also even the gdp per capita doesn't
really tell you how much you can buy
with that per capita gdp and so that's
why people look at things like
purchasing power parity this is a sense
of per capita gdp but adjusted for how
much you could buy with those resources
that are measured in u.s dollars so now
all of a sudden qatar at the top qatar
was pretty high but i guess you can buy
more and get more goods and services
with that nominal gdp per capita is
measured in u.s dollars in qatar than
you could say in the united states
so i will leave you there there's no
such thing as an absolutely perfect
measure of economic activity much less
well-being but gdp is the best measure
that we have although i encourage you to
think of others for example the un has
tried to measure happiness
they have this ranking of happiness they
have an annual world happiness report
and i'm not going to go into all of the
details but beyond gdp it also considers
things like health or other measures of
well-being and as you can see the
countries at the top here tend to have
fairly high gdps but this ranking is not
the same as the ranking that we saw on
the gdp per capita with the purchase
power parity and so these are all very
interesting things to think about